all right we're going to do another
breakdown of the stories that have been
posted
eventually these will get so crystal
clear that you won't need these
additional breakdowns but for now I'll
go ahead and do additional breakdowns as
uh you get more and more constituted
with what is being said and aligning
with uh all facets of the new Earth
Mission so this is a new Earth
meditation that's really good that
includes a lot of the solar Punk visuals
I can play it for a little bit but
you'll find the real uh on any of the
social
platforms Envision the new world the
solar Punk future complete harmony with
Earth complete harmony with each other
basic needs met for all children
frolicking
with so that's about the frequency that
you get from it so it's a it's about
staying constituted as that frequency
the entire game is just being
constituted as the solar Punk frequency
being constituted as the new Earth
frequency just being unshakable never
moving from there you'll hear me say
this over and over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
and then at some point it'll probably
click where that's what you're going to
be you're going to be new Earth new
Earth new Earth new Earth new Earth new
Earth new Earth new Earth all Body
Energy just moving more and more
effortlessly in that direction
constantly that's it that's literally it
and the solar Punk is just that ideal
archetype of the indigenous wisdom
meeting the technological basic needs
free energy
Utopia so this was a really fun one that
came through it's just limitlessness
playing with limits that's basically it
I mean you don't really need to go
further than that I mean down here here
in the later on in the video um it's
been a while by the way in terms of
sleeping so it's it's probably been like
30 approaching 36 hours since I've since
I've slept I've had a pretty funky sleep
schedule so uh pardon some of the the
energetics uh it's a little bit maybe
less and a little bit more kind of like
uh relaxed but we'll see if that
fluctuates throughout so in essence it's
just limitlessness playing with limits I
I mean it's way too easy and that's why
I wrote goat because you're the greatest
of all time there's only you you're the
greatest of all time and you'll notice
later on I talk about okay no one
and basic needs and new earth and anti
Matrix and it's like combining all these
things into one thing which is what
really sort of the Indescribable essence
of what this channel is it's fascinating
stuff so that's what you are
limitlessness playing with limits
this is just ice
bathing really good stuff
man heals the body really
beautifully super super good healing
super good uh just helping work out all
the contractions in the body vehicle
super smart move to do that often if you
can then this photo was extremely
triggering of course because as y all
know uh this is one of the most
quintessential ways of kayab which is
just manipulation it's just absolute
manipulation for self-image totally
Satan faking private jet photos and of
course Satan's just God's minion all
these games that are played are endless
and this is just a measly influencer
that's doing it so what can Global Elite
in bed with tech govs and media do so at
even larger scale so obviously wake up
Neo so and then someone asked me about
what was uh your take on what's
happening behind the scenes of the
Microsoft and open AI bit and I was just
very blatant uh before and I repeated
myself in a way here by saying that the
global Elite Matrix kayfabe is what's
happening and it's absolute corruption a
classic type of Matrix kayfabe where
valuation is artificially pump with
strategic drama just so that's it
valuation artificially pump with
strategic drama it's an ancient dark
arts trick oldest time nothing new Under
the Sun just now the mouth Beast is free
to say it without repressing God bless
this flow how are you
king this is definitely a fave from it
is um without both there is no God flow
most classically a repression of rage
anger for Injustice and therefore no
ignition for New Earth release the valve
so like you got to know how to be
absolutely still and yet also totally
raging for New Earth and if you can
master
those two things which are really one
thing then you win the game and when you
win the game you get to just be [__]
happy and Blissful and INF flow and it's
just an absolute Masterpiece that
creation is but you can only tap into
that if you've really fully given
yourself and all of
your your nonsensical straight jacket
pieces over to that Divine flow that is
uh has no problems at all with things
like uh expressing Rage or anger for
Injustice and that's exactly what the
ignition for the new Earth is so it's a
very deep trap to uh
repress the things that have to flow
through the valve in order to Beyond
past the valve releasing the valve in
order for the god flow to to
flow
dance baby yeah try his best but he just
can't seem to get Kanye fresh H uh yeah
damn just you
[Music]
know definitely got to unv valve the
flow man unv valve it like you to really
[__] like Let Go like Let Go of the
body let it go let it flow let it go let
it flow let the body go let the body
flow let the body go let the body flow
let it go let it flow let the body go
let it flow let the body go Let it go
Let the Body go go go go
go let the body go let the body go let
the body go let the body go let it flow
flow let the body go let the body go let
the body go let it flow flow you know
that's what you you know really just
letting it all go letting it all go you
know so um new Earth alignment and limit
shattering coaching
so um just opening up if you want to um
have assistance in this we're already
doing it for homeow and I'll just
include now the kind of pro new Earth
anti-matrix plus spiritual side of the
coaching so
um limit shattering is another crucial
part of it and it's examples like this
as you see like where someone's replying
about things energetically clicking and
the reflections are kind of what they
need being feel like they feel like
they're a little trapped um what I'll do
is I'll go ahead and I'll pull up for
you
the I'll pull up for you the website so
this is in the bio the Link's in the
description but so that's this is the
you know the projects page and whatnot
there's the that has home da and
simulation this is the
the normal homepage nothing to do but
die into the new Earth basic needs
abundance for all you got exactly what
we just talked about a second ago the
visualizations of new Earth and there's
nothing really to do but build new Earth
and it's the highest expression of God's
Will and then there's this that you
didn't come here to serve fictitious
money in governments but to bring Heaven
to Earth and there's coaching down there
you can also click it up here um so when
you click coaching you'll see I coach
individuals and teams on shattering
limits and alignment with actualizing
their new Earth Visions if you click
this inquire button you'll get a mail
too and you'll be able to email me with
details some of the peeps that I work
with more uh examples of things that I
reflect and how it lands for people
helping them on their
Journeys and then solar Punk this link
also obviously we've kind of went over
that a bit um but yeah it's a freaking
beautiful that's what we're aligning to
and there's some philanthropy stuff with
the up up coming School in boday in
India and there's the books that I've
written I've written three of them what
is I high level perception and riffs on
the ineffable so that's basically it if
you want to get in touch on on coaching
just come here and hit
inquire now let's see how well I can get
this read for y'all cuz some of these
are pretty good um they're like they're
good way that the that we're connecting
with the community
so oh my god I've never seen someone
connect the whole nonself thing to
fighting against the ruling Elites
however that's my verbiage I like how
you keep it simple just breaking out of
the Matrix and the phrase surrender the
whole body to New Earth even the phrase
new Earth in and of itself this is a new
North Star for me thank you for that and
for the channel I could make a new post
every minute to [__] you say it's such a
beautiful comment super grateful and I
said long lost Brothers found let's get
it King so that's really I think that is
basically the core of it is connecting
no self to fighting the ruling Elites
connected to building the new Earth and
uh connected to like anti sing and um
Pro basic needs and free energy and all
that kind of stuff so it's a whole new
North Star like was shared there and
it's so beautiful being able to kind of
spearhead that North Star with y'all
fam
this is also probably one of the most
important images here I mean you can't
the thing is you can't get away from
this I mean you can try your hardest to
find other ways to build the future but
you'll never win because this is the
only way forward that works you have to
biomimic you have to biomimic you have
to biomimic you have to biomimic you
have to biomimic man the trees and the
mushrooms underground are in a perfect
harmonious two-way resource exchange
it's incredible
impeccable and it's super non siloed non
separate it's just a singular unified
Network in that same way we biomimic
with our basic needs Utopia which is
God's will so the highest expression of
God's will is a basic needs Utopia it's
literally being infinite infinitely
creative infinitely abundant that's the
end of the story biomimicry or bust
highest expression of God's will is
basic needs Utopia free energy un un
limited creativity unlimited Bliss joy
peace abundance let's [__] go let's
[__] go this is the
constitutionalization fam this is the
constitutionalization and you see what
we do is we Liberate the silos we
Liberate the the separation so wherever
there's the
Assumption of being something that's
Hoarding in here you know you're
hoarding you're hoarding you're not
sharing like that's exactly where the
catalyst go to
liberate die for
this it's important to realize that you
know we're going to mention that here in
a little bit uh one of my favorite
quotes from this this story sweet
but you really do I mean you're
basically crucifying yourself for this
do you understand what that means you're
crucifying yourself for this okay what
that means is that your lower case s
self is being
crucified whatever selfish intense and
paradigms and programs that it's running
are no longer because they've been seen
through as
completely
futile and so that's what the
crucifixion is the crucifixion is the
absolute cessation of all programs of
selfing the absolute cessation of all
selfing programs that's what crucifixion
is and then you're at nothing being
everything which is you and then all
that is
is New Earth basic needs abundance
prosperity it's pretty simple stuff so
that's what's meant by die for
this this one
too dear men may your daughters meet
guys like you
so
basically this is the best way to
reflect to men to treat women like
divinity and
to um to realize that that daughters
grow up and then interface with men that
are just like you so the better you
are the more that you can be rest
assured that that your daughter is being
treated well by men also and
that
um and we can forgive ourselves like in
the below graphic in the mood to forgive
the versions of me that didn't know any
better exactly
so if you don't know any better you can
forgive
yourself you can forgive
yourself
yeah and there's so much Beauty in
really for giving yourself so much so
much
healing
so so me this is this is really nice CU
um I have a couple workouts in here that
I'm just showcasing and the thing about
this that I want to say is
that notice how it says Get It Kings
right so there's the inspiration and all
the working out is get it Kings like get
going get get pump on the body masculine
mandatory daily pump
homies get it Kings daily pump daily
pump get it so this is what I meant by
the Gigi it's down here I'll go ahead
and I'll spoil it but Enlightenment
reveals the deepest Cause worth dying
for enlightenment reveal is the deepest
Cause worth dying
for
so what we talked about earlier was
crucifixion of self and
so basically that is the Revelation that
all that is is you and the deepest cause
we're dying for is New Earth is
liberating all the contractions in your
root system of your body called
Earth and that's basically what is said
here in the conversation is that Jesus
flipped tables and that embracing
non-duality is through embracing Duality
and
that Enlightenment reveals the deepest
cause we're dying
for so there will be no there will be no
bypassing of embracing Duality it's
impossible
actually the only thing you can do is
actually embrace the role on the stage
and it's inherently dualistic there's no
way around it basically you have to pick
what's good and you have to pick what's
bad and in this case good is basic needs
and abundance for Earth free energy and
bad is Matrix enslavement and limits on
freedom and all kinds of [__] so there's
no other way I mean you can't trip out
in non-duality there is no empty ground
there is no absolute there is no thing
that is transcendent from this there is
only this it's so simple so meaning
you have to die into the character in
its role and that's the deepest Cause
worth dying for is the highest
possibility for
Earth why when this could easily be our
reality do we keep finding ourselves
stuck inside this and then that's where
I commented right away kings and queens
of new Earth stay strong and convicted
in basic needs and free energy abundance
for all we got this I love you so
basically it's impenetrable conviction
of that top graphic and moving via
catalysts more and more of this up to
this here's another one stay constituted
in never waver there is some
conversation happening here
about about uh politics and about um
about vac and that kind of stuff and
there is just a simple very very simple
response there's no partisan there's
only new Earth stay constit ited don't
weigh vers and bio are great for New
Earth also great for dark arts hijacking
be vigilant it's way too simple and
non-conceptual nor elaborative new Earth
only basic needs abundance for all only
nothing else to be added get it
King and then there perhaps only
transmittable face to face or hand in
hand
so just do your best to stay constituted
as it I [__] hate spiritual people
and non-u people that are masturbating
on Concepts all day long equally to as
much as I hate the world economic forum
and the global Elites that and the
bankers that are [__] Contracting
people in Matrix
prison that's such a good one I
definitely recommend watching that
that's a again across all channels as a
clip or a short or a real
Etc
and
um you know I I write here that
realization is non-local omnio and
embodied your body is the Earth and it
has contractions that are asking to be
liberated anyone truly infinite thirst
for this so
meaning
um
meaning when when realized it's realized
that everything is you and that is
obvious that the Earth has contractions
in its root networks which is why
there's so much just
it's just there's so many spiritual
[__] it's just like the spiritual
industrial complex is completely out of
control and all that really matters is
that you know that you're nothing and
that nothing is being everything and
that you're everything that's really all
that matters Nothing Else Matters man
and once you know that you can just be
the
body and then you're the body and then
the body's in some sort of a Free
Falling flow of dualistic war of
infinity war and you're just
representing the good you're
representing new Earth as best as you
can and you're saying [__] you to all of
the Matrix [__] and that's basically
it it's super
simple uh this is a fun one too
especially this one uh it's like
different it's like two different worlds
one Awakening practice non-duality and
two the resistance movement there often
isn't the of overlap but it doesn't have
to remain this way I dream that a lot of
people in the second grouping will one
day find this stuff to spiritual
Tech and I wrote it does feel like we've
activated a new God Mode by combining no
one with new Earth and anti-matrix like
a LeBron or Drake flow to the game so
again activated a new God Mode by
combining no one with new Earth and anti
Matrix wake up Neo I love that man that
combination right there is so freaking
rich
no one new Earth anti-matrix
this is a throwback to
2018 where I wrote this was uh when I
was interviewing Jason Silva in a live
audience it was really super it was fun
I wrote uh never left just been refining
if you know you know like you know just
been refining I've never left cuz you
read this Find meaning in life by
shattering the control Matrix and
pursuing what actualizes your soul so
I've always really been on it it's just
honed in more and more and more
this one's so good this is
you I love that noise and I love the
ripples because this is you I mean
anyone who's taken a anyone who's taken
a psychedelic and looked out at vast uh
swaths of of plants and land is aware
that basically what happens is the body
the the solidity of the body body
dissolves the body becomes kind of
cellular vibrations that are made of
light made of energy and it's clearly
seen that the bodily vibrations are
equivalent in terms of the vibrations of
the plants so the way that the plants
are moving effortlessly in the wind and
all beautifully is the same way that the
body is pulsing and moving like the
heart the gut the blood the um the GI
all that stuff and it's just like
endless endless endless little
vibrational movements nothing is
actually solid and everything is you so
this is the beauty of being able to
really make that a clear Constitution
like this is me like my Earth my body is
the Earth and if my body is the earth
that means all I care about is
constitutionalization as the new world
that's all I care about I don't care
about anything
else you know and if you're actually
like that then we can build a new world
together because what I know is then I
can I can lock arms with you and we can
go out onto the battlefield together cuz
I know that you're literally there to
die you're literally there to die for
the new world that's what crucifixion is
that's what crucifixion is all of
selfing is surrendered to God's will of
new Earth all of selfing is surrendered
to God's will of new
Earth
says you the new [__] that you got is
over do you better publish you supposed
to do I'm like why I could be all that
but still I can't deny the fact that
it's
true you know you can't deny the fact
that it's true that you're destined to
go God Mode for New Earth there's no
denying it it's Destiny it's done it's
written it's just about the selfing
contraction being complet completely
released and liberated from the body and
surrendered to that godf flow for New
Earth there's just nothing else to do my
friend if you realize that you were
empty and you were infinite and that
you had nothing to get out of selfing at
all it would be super obvious to you
that the only thing is this God flow
towards New
Earth this is probably one of my
favorite give it a nice little rotation
one of my favorite uh new Earth
visualizations images definitely save
this one this is also available on the
on the link in the description on the
alens sak.com
solarpunk it's such a good one man this
one is [__] amaz
balls super inspirational super Galactic
Universal it's like free energy basic
needs abundance it's so perfect I love
that
[Music]
one this might be my favorite internet
video of all
[Music]
time that's like the cutest video of all
time I think I think this one wins my
heart forever in terms of best internet
video if if anyone can beat this in
terms of best internet video of all
time then send it to simulation series
gmail.com and if I think it's better
then I will feature it but this is for
sure cutest I love it I love it so much
it's like it radiates pure innocence you
know new Earth is all about pure
innocence this is pure innocence you
know there's no ideas there's no
separation there's no hatd there's no
any of those contractions you know it's
just pure joy Bliss you know sh onand
existence Consciousness SP simple simple
man this is great this full send um so
there was a comment about loving this do
you have a video with more details on
building the new basic needs
infrastructures cheers from Brazil full
send love it uh I wrote bow thanks let's
get it click the homeow website link in
description we just had a call today
with a new community being built in
Brazil full send
so basically Earth being saturated in
light cities with free energy and basic
needs like billions of people living in
light cities that are networked with
free energy and basic needs like obso of
money obsoletion of bartering obso of
everything even travel cost all that
kind of stuff it's just gone you know
and uh I put the link down there for
home da it's also obviously in the
description go and check it out guys
like people ask in the comments all the
time they're like what are you guys up
to man like point me in the direction
and I'm like it's literally in the
description of every video is HED out
like literally just go and look at it
you'll see there's a whole entire white
light paper with tokenomics there it's
[__] beautifully detailed we've spent
so much time on that then we already
have 220 million in assets under
management and projects and the
developers already have tokens and soon
there will be an opening to the to a
network of maybe about a 100 or so
Developers ERS that we're on boarding um
that will also be earning these tokens
that are backed by this pipeline of of
NextGen energy infrastructures housing
communities water food
Etc so join that if you want and just go
Homestead you know Homestead Homestead
Homestead we'll have an opportunity with
the interface soon to make it really
easy to Homestead through the Dow at
incredible um beautiful modern homes for
unbelievably cheap prices like half of
the um average home price in the
US so yeah it'll just depend if you want
to spend more time in the community
areas if you want a homestead there if
you want a homestead solo you
know it's all up to you you know how big
it's all modular to make it how big you
want uh this is a conversation with a
friend I said uh lots of deep pains
getting surfaced and metabolized in our
networks and Collective The Awakening is
igniting rapidly it's more important
than ever for the mouthpiece to be freed
by God's flow to take a stand and I love
that you did beautiful keep it up Queen
so more than ever it's crucial for the
mouthpiece to be freed by God's flow to
take a stand be completely Freed at the
mouthpiece allow allow allow the flow
everything allow ev Everything every
everything
everything this is another good one one
this is from bentino's recent post
whenever it feels like God is slamming
every door in your face and is actively
busy striking you down just remember
that God can only strike down what is
not you what is false and he does so
precisely to help you know that you
really are what you really are so let
God dismantle the Illusions and let go
into the pure you that remains cooperate
with his agenda and as you thus allow
yourself to be liberated from the false
wants and obsessions which kept you in
bondage by your own ignorant will you
will realize that God's Wrath was in
truth God's love all along and that
God's will is your
will so this last part is also just so
good it's like only the false can die so
as the false dies the true is revealed
and the true is that everything's you
and that you're the universe and that
that's love and that uh any type of
Wrath is just destroying the false and
it's always God's love and that that
will is your
will this is another good one with new
Earth Energy I love this one it's like
it's a comment from one of the recent
videos that's like about the stop sing
and build a new world and it's like I
like this energy feels like you stepped
into your manhood masculinity and
expressing the one and only through it
the time of being a passive bystander is
over we need to go out in the world and
stand for what is right instead of
staying in our comfortable spiritual
bubbles make the people Waging War
conscious of their stupid
unconsciousness what are we afraid to
lose by doing this our body who cares if
truth brings the physical death so be it
Jesus did not fault he stay true when
bodily death was coming a spiritual mute
heck no a spiritual Warrior heck yes yes
King let's get it you know this one's so
good man this one's so good like dude
sacrifice
all of the body surrender all of the
body crucify every single cell
everything to God to God's will for New
Earth you know spiritual Warrior for the
new Earth baby I love it I love the new
Earth Energy in the family in the
channel it's so
good this is also good from my uh post
from my friend mesh this is from um
sadara mesuar
Maharaj
um I excerpt from amut Lia and this was
recommended to him by Ben the pause
between two states is nothing but pure
Consciousness the state of The Silent
One is such that he does not allow a
single word to rise or even if he did
rise he does not allow its meaning to
rise but simply lets it slip by when the
word Rises and is allowed to impress its
meaning in the inner mind that's when
the world is born ignoring the word and
not allowing it to carry any meaning for
the mind is the eradication of the world
when the word does not energize the mind
what remains is the pure energy of
Consciousness to experience the state
continuously is called the state of
Silence so
basically if you just catch that that
basically a concept like a con like a
conceptual holographic projection is
happening in essence and so if you're
just watching and you realize that oh
when there's no conceptual projection
and there's no first of all there's no
objectification and then there's no
conceptual projection that's happening
it's just obvious that nothing is
happening it's obvious that there's only
pure Consciousness that's happening it's
obvious that that's everything that
that's love that that's you at the most
fundamental way but you sort of have to
in a way if you're still kind of trying
to identify what self-realization is you
basically have to get really good at at
unhooking from object objectification
and then you kind of learn to relax more
and more at has like subjectivity with
uh the conceptual kind of like
conceptual projecting and whatnot and
then you notice that they're actually
isn't even a subject that the subject
itself is nothing and therefore that is
true peace that is true Stillness that
is pure Consciousness that is bliss
existence peace Joy it's all those
things and it's also the the obvious uh
flow of God's will for New Earth when
there's no one home it just becomes
obvious that the only way that the
current of the body moves is towards New
Earth here's another very direct
pointing from sidara mishwar
and I'll just read the highlights here
because they're so good as long as
objects are taken to truly exist until
then only the sear remains and then all
objects depend on the concept of the
sear but Brahman is beyond concept and
no concept can conceive it you see if
you call it wood it's wood if you call
it chair it's chair if you call it
Brahman it's Brahman you know call it
world it's World Etc so as long as you
notice that objects are depending on
these concepts of the sear and that
really what the sear is is this pure
Consciousness which is nothing being
everything and Brahman is beyond concept
and no concept can conceive of
it
this was funny in that same
video
uh we get there in a sec so in that same
video on stop the simp which I know I
wrote like
um I wrote something like like stop
Matrix sing is what I wrote like stop
Matrix sing and build new Earth but I
like stop the S it reminds me of stop
stop the steel and I like stop the S
because basically that's the in terms of
the essence of what anti-matrix is I
would actually say it's stop the simp
the essence of anti-matrix is stop the
simp because what the simp is it's not
just subscribing to only fans and stuff
it's actually even more so it's sing to
Daddy government that's probably the
biggest one it's simping to corporations
and simping to money as God it's simping
to your own selfing mechanism so your
own desires for validation and
worthiness and that kind of stuff it's
simping for uh mommy and daddy's
approval and so what's happening is
there's all kind that program of simping
that's running it is outsourcing
sovereignty it is outsourcing God's will
will to some sort of like a program it's
like a satanic program and that has it's
it's has its own agenda and that agenda
is any of those simping things and it
basically takes God's Will and hijacks
it and diverts it into its own selfing
mechanisms and that's a total disaster
for the new Earth so meaning the most
optimal way in terms of building new
Earth is actually through the
destruction of the programs that are
about
sing most optimal way for New Earth is
destruction of sing programs anywhere
where you simp you are not free simping
is unfreedom is not Freedom sing is the
opposite of
Freedom
so and that's why we have to use the
Duality you know non-dualist will be
like oh you're free to simp also you
know and see you see the game that that
that they play with that and whatnot but
the D ists are able to have that clear
discernment and say that or the
simultaneous or whatever you want to
call it super
positionist where they can clearly
discern and discriminate and say that no
this is all sing and that's all
contraction it's all selfing and I'm in
the direction of the
vessel for God's flow for basic needs
abundance
with the be now they got a [__] on
replay sorry I'm in pajamas but I just
got out the PJ Let's
Jam down
PR be free man so important be free and
move the body be free be free be free be
free move the body move the body be free
what's up where myy at you going make me
come down to your
house it's so important so important to
move the body so important you got to
move the body you got to move the body
got to move the body got to move the
body freely got to move the body freely
so important multiple times a day every
single day stretch it out move it around
open up all the contractions in the body
I love this one too wow nothing just
what I always wanted it's such a direct
pointing you know you'll never find it
because you're already it and what it is
is nothing it's super simple honestly it
doesn't take eons of seeking or any of
that nonsense it's actually already here
and it's just there's avoidance of it
basically is what's happening so if you
don't want to if you don't want to
identify as nothing what you'll do is
you'll avoid it and when you avoid it
then a whole world World manifests of
separation and all kinds of
stuff then you're hijacked by those
programs instead of being that empty
vessel for God's flow to new new
Earth and uh some more Channel comments
good ones goated vid bra greatest of all
time vid I [__] love that Fam thank
you King let's get it um and then that
was from the the second comment was from
the interview with Aaron ABY that we
started by going
with all that nonsense and the one of
the comments really loved that and
wanting to find someone like that and I
said yes find the others that
can that can uh rival your ability to
play
nonsense and then there was a comment on
one of the IG reals about that was the
first time that they had heard the
phrase spiritual industrial complex to
describe the the spiritual Seeker with
the guru's testicles in their mouth for
the whole incarnation
and it's a great acronym it's SI I sick
and nothing can replace the crucifixion
of everything false and what remains is
obvious this is some more awesome uh
Community love you know well said man
said thanky King it's a good video on
real self-realization check that one out
if you haven't yet and then another one
is your passion is inspiring for me
thank you brother I said pass along the
passion as new Earth C
sister and then same person I love what
you say thank you friend I said grateful
for our
family this is an interesting bit
so so someone was responding to me and
mentioning like hey like what Matrix
prisons are being built and by the way
vaccines have been around quite a while
now and you also have many so they are
quite useful and I said Matrix prisons
are mega cities completely saturated by
corruption the lockdowns jab cbdc 0.1%
Elites inflating as obvious dark arts
absolute disrespect for poor and middle
class nature and Harmony it's all
generating separation with Elite escape
velocity it has nothing at all to do
with the highest expression of God's
will of holism unity abundance and
prosperity for all it is the opposite of
a singular organism called nature
working in harmony it is a separationist
and speciation movement that is
vacuuming everything for
itself I will read that again
listen it is a separationist and
speciation movement that is vacuuming
everything for
itself you see it's simple
speciation [__] you guys basically [__]
you guys [__] you poor middle class
vacuum everything for ourselves and then
boom that last line laying out the plans
in Plain Sight using Hollywood to show
blueprints like elisium to their human
cattle so boom
gone human cattle we don't care we're
off and it's really just the pretending
to be ignorant cuz we all see it I mean
it's blatantly obvious it like even a
small child is now able to see
corruption and like it's funny like like
pretending like 30-year-olds and
60-year-olds and whatever all these ages
like oh I don't know what you're talking
about man what a joke man I don't know
what you're talking about regarding
corruption man what the [__] what a
[__] dweeb oh it's so
funny H there's a comment in the chat
about age yeah I'm 31 31
fam all right so we'll continue here the
resistance movement is New Earth
sovereignty light cities with free
energy and basic needs
abundance it needs to be the constant
constitutionalization of the masculine
Warriors in the feminine support it's
already done the awareness of the Dark
Arts of the infinity War generates
Catalyst to exit and build to annihilate
Matrix programs running in beep booping
zombie Minds I love science and biology
it's how God expresses itself in nature
it can be used for incredible medicine
which is the direction New Earth is
taking it it can also be hijacked in
Endless Ways by the dark arts which we
are only beginning to see the strategies
of stay vigilant and sword
wielded again that's that second bit
with the rainbow there the resistance
movement is New Earth sovereignty light
cities with free energy and basic needs
abundance that's truly it that's truly
it
so let's exit and build let's
Homestead let's get into these
communities
together another good one get ripped
Kings get ripped Kings get those abs get
those abs get them baby get them get
them get them get them let's go fam
let's go get it get it masculine Kings
get it get it fam love you get working
out get working out take good care of
the of the body vehicle
fam all right um this is this is good
this is a more of a nerdy way of
describing what um I'm saying here and
this is with also one of my friends Nick
hamus there I wrote at the bottom helped
inspire me with this but in terms of
math and Ai and biology and also even
physics our anill Earth is one locked
into a local maximum so that's that's
this here you can see that's that's the
local maximum right there and two when
there is a collectively expansive Global
maximum so this is a local maximum this
is a global maximum and it takes
Catalyst to move the hive to the new
Peak so meaning here's ants ants are
running around this this local maximum
which is current Earth and it takes
Catalyst and resource to move the ants
to this higher Global maximum that's
expansive called the new Earth with
decentralized basic needs abundance
prosperity for all you can look at new
Earth as an increase in Creative
potential being actualized you can
see right you can see the fluctuations
here are just the Divine Sparks and
whatnot whereas here it's like kind of
like
uh so that's an
example that this is called the hill
hill climbing
algorithm
so you can use endless ways to point at
um at what it looks like to move from
the old to the
new and certain ones can be more
relatable for people with all these
different
angles this one's pretty beautiful too
um there's a comment up there making me
come alive bro I said love it King let's
go and then another comment Amen brother
I said amen sister and I love your
perspectives friend thank you I said
Thank You Queen I love you and that the
channel energy is on fire no limits on
the mouthpiece Pure Freedom all straight
jackets and valves obliterated Ragnar
leonitis online and if you don't know
who Ragnar is from Vikings or leonitis
is from 300 I highly recommend studying
them because that's the Pinnacle of
divine masculine and if you can really
embod that and completely sacrifice your
sense of self to the mission which is
building new Earth like these Warriors
do that's game over man that's the
crucifixion Manion we going to fall
let's get it Kings every day baby let's
get it you like my f coat baby let's go
let's go get those pull-ups
baby take good care of the body
fam get the pump every day
so and then this last story this is the
blueprint if it makes you wet then build
it and there's a link to the solar Punk
Gallery again the link in the bio in the
description is the Allens sak.com and
then you'll see up there at the top is
solar
Punk and so if you take a look at this
Gallery man you take a look at this
gallery and you
are inspired and this is sort of this is
the bodily
constitutionalization process
you see It'll slowly more and more
constitutionalize as this and nothing
else and it'll only be excited about
this and you'll feel more and more of
God within feel more and more of God
within you'll feel Divine and
beautiful all right
so boom
boom all right I mean that's uh that's
pretty much it
get inspired and you know access these
resources whenever you need to if you
want to again you can reach out for
coaching in inquiry there
um
and I'll do these I'll do these more
often I wanted to make sure that
um at least if I'm going to be doing
these big story dumps that I'm going to
be at least breaking down the stories
via the stream and then kind of like
having that be uh like kind of where the
frequency of the of the show is at and
um further generating kind of
constitutionalization and Catalyst with
it so um so I'll probably do that
whenever I do a round of posting I mean
it'll be good to bring people on like if
if people want to make clips of what's
being said and then send them to
simulation series at gmail
I will gladly post them and then credit
and all that stuff that would also be
very helpful like making a
decentralized engine of of content in
that sense and um and eventually just
post it on on your own accounts with
with the home Dow and that kind of stuff
to kind of inspire people and solar Punk
to kind of inspire people in that way so
I mean that's where that's where we see
things heading and
um and that's it that's it fam
all right fun sash uh drop a comment
below with your thoughts would' like to
hear from you give the video a like
support it support in the algo and uh
subscribe if you haven't yet share the
vid if you feel like it's relevant with
someone and and check out the links
again in the bio and uh much love much
much love everything is always already
here everything the Eternal peace is
always
here and at the same time is the flow of
the warrior for New Earth super simple
stuff nobody's doing it it's just
Freedom
[Music]
flowing